the doom slayer is essentially a super
soldier a space marine with superhuman
abilities
who can run super fast react with super
speed fall from great heights without
taking damage
and carry large amounts of ammo only
also rips the demon's heads off
and shoves them down their throats and
as though that wasn't already enough
he then chose to stay in hell to battle
demons indefinitely
so yeah he's kind of a badass what can
we take from this though and apply to a
useful
functional workout actually a surprising
amount
but just a quick disclaimer as with many
of these fictional character inspired
workouts
i'm using this as a fun way to discuss
some cool training concepts and ideas
i'm presenting them here for your
further research and consideration
rather than as recommendations these are
out there approaches that may have some
benefit for the wider population
but i'm certainly not claiming these are
ideas for everyone
nor does this represent a complete
training program or prescription
think of it as a thought experiment and
take from it what you will
so the doom slayer is a marine so the
foundation of this training should be
inspired by military training
and this actually translates perfectly
to the traits that we just listed
seeing as the military favor strength
endurance mental toughness
and the ability to carry heavy loads
sound familiar
one of the best methods that the
military used to train these features
specifically
is wrecking rocking involves taking
heavy load strapping it to your back and
then walking long distances
often this is more like a light jog
though on uneven terrain
the simple fact is that infantry need to
be able to perform while carrying heavy
guns and lots of equipment
this is doubly true for doomguy who
seems to carry around an entire arsenal
on his back
rocking of course is one of the best
ways to develop and to test this ability
rocking will build that mental endurance
as well as cardiovascular fitness
strength endurance and even hip and
ankle stability as you adapt to the
uneven ground
it burns a ton of calories in one study
walking with added weight burns 12
more calories than just walking alone
and it's relatively safe
as long as you build up to it gradually
a good recommendation is to start with
roughly 10
of your body weight if you're more
experienced with training
then of course you can go significantly
above this weight rapidly
but start light to get a feel for it
this is also a great option for
incidental training
if you have to walk somewhere throw on a
heavy backpack or a weighted vest and
get some extra bang for your buck
30 minutes is a good amount of time to
start with but you can aim to increase
the distance you cover in this time
and whilst we're carrying heavy stuff
i'd also argue that our doomslayer
workout could benefit from adding
farmers walks
and other forms of loaded carries this
basically means picking up something
heavy holding onto it and walking a
distance
this excellent form of training builds
grip strength which is useful for
ripping demon's jaws off
and if we use one-sided carriers like
the suitcase carry then we'll also be
able to build anti-lateral flexion in
the core
and strengthen the obliques vary walking
with a heavy bag
rocking and carrying something and that
way you'll build even more robust and
rugged performance take it onto uneven
terrain for even more devastating
strength and conditioning
in fact this is starting to look a lot
like something that a user recently
shared with the patrons only bioneers
group on facebook recently
the sprint drag carry or sdc
this is a test of strength endurance and
anaerobic capacity
and it's one of six events used in the
army combat fitness test
here soldiers will sprint to a 25 meter
mark and then back
grab a 90 pound sled and then drag it
backwards to and from the 25 meter line
making sure that the entire sled crosses
the line each time
and then perform a lateral dash sideways
to and from the line
[Music]
finally they run to and from the line
again while holding two 40-pound
[Music]
kettlebells
they then finish on a final sprint
you can try this yourself by finding a
field and using a heavy bag attached to
a rope
mark the distance with cones
and for those interested the other five
events in the army combat fitness test
consist
of three repetition maximum deadlift
standing power throw which is launching
a medicine ball overhead and behind you
hand release push-ups which are push-ups
where you raise your hands from the
ground at the bottom of each movement
thus
losing any momentum the leg tuck is
effectively a tuck front lever but for
reps
whilst using a commando neutral pull-up
grip
and a two mile run and then of course
the sprint drag carry itself
this is actually a pretty interesting
combination of functional movements
and they'd be right at home in a
doomslayer workout
the sdc has a bunch of unique benefits
in itself though for one it's a form of
what's known as cardio acceleration
there's my love of training methods with
awesome names again cardiac acceleration
basically means performing some form of
cardiovascular training
aerobic or anaerobic between sets of
resistance training
rather than resting so this keeps the
heart rate high during your resistance
training and it therefore burns a ton of
calories
and really tests your endurance and it's
also just grueling
of course it's not ideal for primarily
strength or hypertrophy oriented
training
as it does limit the amount you can lift
for our purposes here
energizer money style ripping and
tearing it's perfect
i would also warn against using cardio
acceleration alongside technical or very
heavy lifts
we don't want to be performing deadlifts
whilst exhausted for obvious reasons
as an added bonus the backwoods strag is
also great for the knees
as any fans of ben patrick nizovito's
guy will know
i would argue that you could also place
a crawling dragon here for extra credit
a crawling drag works the upper and
lower body in a way that translates to
faster sprinting
and a stronger core it's also great for
coordinated movement of the limbs
and it's a concentric only exercise
meaning that there's minimal muscle
damage allowing you to train harder
whilst keeping recovery time short
another form of training that's used
regularly in the military
is high rep calisthenics that means high
reps of push-ups pull-ups and the
classic
burpees which i just made a video on
recently they can be trained for high
repetitions with minimal risk of
injury as long as you're in good shape
to begin with they are once again
perfect for improving strength endurance
and work capacity
a doom slayer workout shouldn't be about
lifting something really heavy once
but rather being able to exert lots of
strength for a long amount of time
without tiring out or losing power this
is simply more useful and practical in a
real world setting
burpees are a hybrid exercise that use
both the upper and lower body
this increases the heart rate
significantly as blood needs to get to
the muscles on the opposite sides of the
body
while also building a lot of stability
as you move between positions
and because burpees are explosive they
encourage fast powerful movement
and we can make this even tougher by
adding a little extra weight
in one cool study it was found that
oxygen consumption was increased by an
impressive 100 percent
during military-style training programs
using a weighted vest
alternatively you can make a burpee more
challenging by holding dumbbells and
adding a shoulder press
at the end and this is what we call a
devil press again i discussed this in my
video on burpees
the main devil press certainly seems
appropriate for a doomslayer workout
and in fact hybrid exercises make a lot
of sense in general because they teach
dynamic movement especially when
fatigued
if we're going to be grappling with
demons though then we also need
rotational strength the good news is
that there are countless different
variations on the burpee or devil press
that we can incorporate for similar
benefits
again i listed loads of these in the
recent video
the man maker for example is like a
devil press but with a renegade row
added in
then there are the one legged burpees
there are kicking burpees
dead stop burpees mountain climber
burpees side burpees single arm burpees
spider burpees skate up jump burpees
lateral jumping burpees broad jump
burpees punching burpees
the list goes on and if you want to take
this to the next level then you can set
yourself the challenge of performing any
mixture of these
alongside regular push-ups this becomes
something like a flow but instead of a
movement flow it's more like an
explosive calisthenics
or athletic flow we see flows used a lot
in kettlebell training as well
and this is also where we see a lot of
hybrid exercises
for example you might flow from a
kettlebell swing to a clean to a press
to a kneeling get-up the kettlebell
similarly lends itself perfectly to
training strength endurance and
explosiveness
but even better is that training with
flows like this or any sequence of
movement
creates more need for decision making
and focus the awesome thing about
playing the new doom games in particular
is that they force you to think like the
doom slayer these are intense battles
that don't let up
they require expert resource management
target prioritization
visual processing focus and tactics i
highly suspect that doom eternal in
particular may actually be a very useful
form of brain training
we know from research that any first
person shooter has a lot of benefits for
the brain
but i genuinely believe that do maternal
steps it up a notch
and this is where more complex sequences
of movements have an edge over simple
repetitions
because they force you to focus and they
force you to think about your next
movement
give yourself a string of movements to
perform such as a kick through left kick
through right
burpee 100 up 45 degree bound in each
direction
burpee repeat while this isn't
particularly complex
you're now having to focus carefully on
the movements and keep track of what
you've already done
if you're going to complete the sequence
correctly you just can't let your mind
wander
i've also discussed in the past how
training movements in a more random
order
can actually improve skill acquisition
and retention if you're training for
basketball say
it makes sense to practice a dribble a
pass and a shot
rather than chunking those actions
together as separate drills
and this makes sense it forces you to
concentrate and it's exactly how you
really use those skills in competition
this is another reason that performing
three sets of ten isolation movements
may be a little outmoded the technical
term is contextual interference
and it's worth looking up keep in mind
though that contextual interference
is very much dependent on the nature of
the skill the level of the trainee
and a lot more and with all that said we
could even go a step further
what if we were to throw in brain
training between sets if you have one
minute to recover between sets
why not spend that minute doing a dual
n-back test or some version of the
wisconsin card sorting test
or perhaps a street task not only is
this a time efficient way to train both
body and mind
but it also trains you to think clearly
and calmly during high stress
in this case physiological stress which
can act as a kind of stand-in for
emotional stress
this is one of the differentiators when
it comes to optimal athletic performance
and if there ever is a real crisis
you're able to think clearly
even though you're highly stressed is
what's going to make all the difference
i mean imagine if doom guy was just
whimpering in the corner or just
overwhelmed and distracted
he'd hardly be the cool character that
we think of him as
i've also suggested in the past that
using some form of stop and go test
to begin the next set could be an
effective way to incorporate brain
training
in other words a third party gives you a
signal to begin the next movement
or a dummy and you have to react
accordingly this calls to mind the
military's use of the hooded box test
an exercise that involves placing a
trainee under a hood that completely
blocks their vision and hearing
the hood is then suddenly removed to
reveal an unexpected scenario
this could be a combat scenario or an
old lady asking for the time
the job of the trainee is then to
respond appropriately
and to display situational awareness and
it also desensitizes them to the fear
response over time
one study found that a combination of a
stop signal task a go no-go task
stroop task and visual search task could
be effective at reducing civilian
casualties
among military personnel in short
incorporating brain training in these
ways
could well be an effective method for
building a truly unstoppable machine
like
doomguy
and i'd like to end with a fun idea
training in heat of course doomguy got
most of his training
in hell which is famously hot and this
could actually have an interesting
impact on a person's performance
you see darpa actually has a history of
trying to create super soldiers
check out my old post on the
metabolically dominant soldier program
which is a really awesome name again one
method they experimented with was using
cooling gloves to enhance
performance this works by improving
thermal regulation in the individual
and thus preventing overheating during
training without the use of cooling
gloves
one interesting option that might be
available could be to train with a sauna
suit
in one study it was found that training
in a sauna suit could lead to
improvements in vo2 max
ventilatory threshold and thermal
regulation
often think about sauna suits in
relation to weight loss but it seems
that there might be some significant
performance benefits too
this is all pretty hypothetical and it
likely wouldn't have enough of an effect
to be worth it for most people but it
could explain why the doomslayer is so
unrelenting finally i do also think that
a doomslayer workout should incorporate
some heavy lifting
a power day of big lifts would fit in
here really nicely
after all doom guy is strong and it's
that combination
of amazing strength with grit focus and
endurance that makes him
truly unstoppable so hope you found this
video useful and interesting guys
if you did please leave a like and share
around that really does help me out and
i appreciate it so much
let me know in the comments how you
would program a doomslayer workout
if you like this kind of mind body
training for human performance
then you might like to check out my
ebook and training program super
functional training
the program is designed to improve every
aspect of human performance
from mobility to strength to
explosiveness to focus to decision
making
and more there's a link below and it's
on discount whilst we're all struggling
with a pandemic
i also have an actual print book called
functional training and beyond
that's an introduction to the concept of
functional training and super functional
training
as they pertain to the general
population it has loads of examples of
incredible human performance
whatever the case thank you so much for
watching this one and for all your
support
subscribe if you want to see more like
this and hit the bell notification
button
to make sure you don't miss future
videos thanks guys
and bye for now